hey y'all do you love middle ground
i know i do did you know that every
purchase made at the jubilee shop helps
fund this show if you're looking for
ways to support jubilee and watch more
episodes of middle ground make sure you
check out our merch at
shop.jubileemedia.com
honestly every one of your purchases
goes such a long way and we're so
grateful for you and enjoy this episode
every single year of my sex of my sex
education we had to sign an abstinence
vow in our books we actually had a
teacher get written up because she
taught the girls sex ed class how to put
on a condom
[Music]
my name is jeremy what i love about
being in the country is being in that
bubble of people that you know and you
care about one of the misconceptions is
people in the city think that people in
the country are like less educated when
i hear city teens i think of party
people
my name is mandy i am from la and i love
it because of the character one second
you're seeing someone a model walking
down the sidewalk the next a homeless
man is peeing on the ground when i hear
country teen i just assume they're kind
of just don't have a lot of experience
with people from different walks of life
in the city i've always felt included
i've always had a friend group and
people to relate to
step forward if you agree
city teens are bitter than country teens
well of course city teens are more
bitchier than sorry mom and dad of
course city teams are more bitchier than
um
country teams because you guys have so
much more
to deal with it's just kind of a role
out of safety where you don't even make
eye contact with anyone because then
you're putting yourself at risk because
there's unfortunately
a lot more bad people that are willing
to do bad things in the city
can they disagree a step forward
i want to say i'm a selfless person i'm
a nice person
however you know i have that side
me coming out as like a is now
just me making sure you know who i am
and how i am going to run my things in
the city like even just driving everyone
else is so like selfish and
self-important where they're getting
where they want to be even if they're
putting other people in danger i almost
had a heart attack this morning
when so many cars like especially like
in the city
they'll just cut you off
the drivers they don't care at all so
i'm like okay so that's normal
people learn more practical life skills
in the country
i grew up in a huge family of like eight
siblings and we've always lived on a
farm and i've had a lot of like life
skills like now i know about plumbing
and like water tanks and different
things that i can now use in like my
adulthood like now that i'm not living
at home my my hometown specifically the
upstate south carolina is considered
like industrial so we have a lot of
factories so they teach you a lot of
very practical hands-on skills woodwork
auto parts auto body in my opinion aaa
is not going to help you in the country
yeah you have to learn how to i had to
learn to change my tire multiple times
before i actually fully understood how
to change my tire i've never done it
once in my life my my dad makes sure we
i keep a jack in my car just in case of
that would you say it's more encouraged
for you to do more of that trade stuff
that you learn or do they encourage you
to say hey feel free to go out into the
city and learn the technology they give
you the option but going into the
workforce was always a good option for
people who maybe couldn't have afforded
it in xyz and stuff like that yeah
personally i've decided not to go to
college at this moment even though i
graduated this past year and i feel like
i have enough skills to the point where
i could get like jobs that don't require
a four-year degree
a big part of practical life school is
like human interaction and i think in
the city you have a lot of opportunities
to meet a lot of diverse people um
different kinds of people you have the
ability to network well would you
consider that social skills or practical
skills um i think social skills are
definitely are a practical skill but i
feel like in the city you learn some you
learn skills that are also equally
useful to living in the state they're
just not the same ones right like
one thing i think about a lot is uber
everyone in the city knows that if if
something doesn't work out something
goes wrong there's always an uber
assuming you have money there's always
like an option someone you can contact
whereas if you're in i mean the middle
of nowhere there's not going to be an
uber period moving to charlotte was
definitely culture shock for me i didn't
know how to use a parking meter
i charged myself four times on a parking
meter because i didn't know how to use
it would you consider that a practical
skill that's the question right because
what is a practical skill in now
societies knowing how to use a parking
meter
that's odd to think about exactly when i
moved there i just didn't know and
that's why i refused to even go towards
the city limits
i had sex education in school
every single year of my sex of my sex
education we had to sign an abstinence
vow in our books we actually had a
teacher get written up because she
taught the girls sex ed class how to put
on a condom i think the importance that
schools place on sex education is
extremely lacking why aren't we worried
about um how good of people we're going
to be because sex education also
includes you know sexual assault rape
like once we put our mindset into we
need to educate on things not just
science math reading
that's how you create better students
that's how you create better people my
parents wanted to like have me learn it
from them because my family's like very
christian that everyone has a different
view of how they think about sex so i
think sometimes it's important to have
like parents teach that to kids i don't
know if it should solely be on schools
which i don't think it should but the
problem is a lot of parents won't as a
woman we're not taught a lot about our
anatomy and our health as much as we
should um i was diagnosed with pcos
polycystic ovarian syndrome with periods
and that kind of stuff we're not taught
like what's normal what's not normal
we're just taught you have one i got
hospitalized because of my condition
because i didn't know about it i wasn't
taught about it and i feel like there's
more to sex education than just
intercourse
people in the city have access to better
education
where i'm from it was very
underdeveloped 30 minutes away
there was private schools there's always
a private school with the better
education better funding and we were
having to
have teachers travel just because of how
horrible our conditions were at my
school and these kids will go to ivy
league colleges where i'm going to
community i think there's a lot more of
a requirement to be educated in the city
if you don't get like a certain quality
of education like your your options are
just not going to be good enough to
afford a lot of the lifestyles that
people live in the city where i'm from
it's the workforce blue collars where
the people who provide
for
for the rest of america so if we can
find a job without our education that's
more important because that's what's
putting food on the table why are we
going to break our bank if we're just if
we can find a job without one
the school that i went to basically like
there was a lot less people there and
there was more help for people that
needed it and like one-on-one time with
teachers so i would say like that's the
reason i've seen a lot of like country
schools having higher like test scores
and all that stuff the high school that
i go to it's heavily funded there was
one time i did go to an inner city
school and i was like whoa like
this is different they don't have what
we have like i hate to bring this up but
like you know sometimes when you go to
those inner city schools who do you see
the most in those schools and that's
when it comes
into the race factor it's been seen in
history that more black and hispanic
schools they often are less funded than
these
pwis do you think that's because of
their race or because of just where
those people tend to live
like we can start a whole entire
conversation about redlining and how
they're all packed there and somehow
they always end up to have
the least funded schools but that's a
whole entire other conversation
i have a diverse group of friends
i have a lot of people who don't view
the world that i do if we're not
christian who are atheist stuff like
that so i think it's important to have
those friends because like as a
christian you're called not to just like
be in a bubble and not just be friends
with people that agree with you because
that's just an echo chamber that doesn't
do any good i would say it's like always
a great opportunity to be able to learn
new things from new people
and really expand yourselves i would say
my main group though is mostly asian
american because that's where i find
common ground with people it's about
what you have in common sometimes what
you don't have in common
i think friends are a luxury i've never
had a set group of friends growing up
i've always been
the weird homo in the background um i
was that token friend i was the token
gay and it was never i wanted to hang
out i just wanted you as my arm candy at
school always the white girls just never
never want to hang out with me in public
and always want to hang out with me in
front of their friends my like my
friends are just the people i see at
work or the people i just kind of i'm
kind of around because i know my
boyfriend has a has a big friend group
and i'm just around them i know i'm
never going to feel like i fit in it's
just that one insecurity that i know i'm
never gonna
find that friend group that is gonna
stick with me forever
i feel safe where i live
i'm a tall white dude at least that's
what that's what people see and like
that's a huge security in the city and i
know i have friends who are not tall not
white not dudes like changing all those
three factors
determines kind of where you feel safe
and has a lot more to do with like
me rather than just like my area or the
city itself yeah personally like growing
up on a farm and predominantly in the
city or in the country there's not very
many like dangers like you can just be
home alone at like age 10.
no one's really gonna like bother you a
lot of people have guns so if people are
not scared of other people it's more
like
natural disasters or like animals or
different things like that i was talking
with some of my family members and they
were like oh now that you live like by
yourself in the country maybe you should
get something like bear spray because
that's more of a threat than someone
like coming to the house and like trying
to rob us
yeah uh i carry around a personal alarm
with me wherever i go i keep it in my
bag because
i want to be able to pop it open and
alert everyone around me to be like hey
i'm small and i might go missing like i
feel the need to have those things
unfortunately and it sucks that i do i
know someone brought up guns um in the
countryside for me in the city guns are
scary not protection because if someone
has a gun in the city they're not
protecting you
they're likely going to shoot you i had
a school shooting in by my neighborhood
so it's definitely something where you
know it's hard to feel safe even going
to school you know in the country you
rarely ever hear things happen like that
like i guess it's just a luxury that we
have in the country you can just walk
around maybe go on a late night jog or
whatever you know things that you can't
really do in the city
i want to switch lives with the other
side
um i've seen what it's like to be in the
city and i feel like especially in the
city there's like way more opportunities
i really wanted to get to get into you
know acting and stuff like that like in
texas you don't really see that much of
that there's always something going on
in the city which is great but it also
means and there's always all kinds of
different people but it'd be nice to
like spend some time just being in the
country and figuring like stuff out for
myself i feel like i'm like literally
the opposite of you i i want a change of
pace i want mine to be faster even
slower
when i was a kid i've always wanted to
like live in new york city and do that
whole thing and do like fashion but
obviously like everyone's opinions
change and what they want to do changes
so i know
personally i want to end up in the
country and just like live on land or
live somewhere that's very peaceful and
like not super busy i personally love
city life like i love city life so much
that i went from la to new york city
which is even more city than la i did
live in georgia for a little under half
my life but just from personal
experience
as like a minority um we tend to be less
accepted where there's less of us and
when i lived in georgia there weren't a
lot of asian people
when i was a kid like i would overhear
people making fun of my mom's accent my
dad's accent about how they spoke to
compare to where i live now those things
don't happen as often i love my quiet
life i love living on the outskirts i
love just
not having to worry about much but my
bills to me success and happiness
don't go together if that's me living
just where i am what i'm doing right at
this moment that's okay it was
interesting to me with you guys both
being minorities in the countryside just
seeing how you experienced being in the
country because i think it's a
stereotype that you know there's a lot
of people that are ignorant and bigoted
in the country rather than the city it's
more accepting i feel like we
all of us are more on the same
wavelength than i think our parents had
with you know people from different
walks of life like if we were to meet
again the word country wouldn't come to
my mind at all like at any point it
would just be like you know
peers
i would hand shake but you know
[Music]
you